please to have here on the Rich Eisen
show right now hopefully at some point
gonna get his Los Angeles Dodgers on a
field in 2020
and it looks like there is a proposal on
the table that could lead to that he is
a former manager of the year he is a
World Series champion in his own right
as a player he is Dave Roberts how are
you sir
rich I'm doing well man it's good to
kind of reconnect and I love listen to
the show and hear passion from sports
fans not great it's the best it really
is and you know under these
circumstances where obviously the world
is different right now but this is one
reason why we certainly need sports back
I love it yeah it's funny I had my buddy
from NFL Network Michael Irvin on last
week and when I texted I'm like you want
to come on the show and he's just like
absolutely he was I feel like I need to
talk sports again it's been so long
since I've talked sports and that's kind
of where we are in this world with me
sitting right here at this show not not
to you know get too deep with you but
again you're a guy who's who manages
right so maybe you can manage me in a
way that I kind of go back and forth by
do I want to talk about the real world
in terms of what's going on in sports or
just you know talk to you about that
2004 season with the Red Sox or your
favorite moment as a player or your
favorite moment is a mad you know like I
kind of go back and forth about it Dave
yeah I'm with you rich and it's
interesting is like I think it's like
it's funny is I talked to my wife and my
kids all the time and it's interesting
because to understand and appreciate
what's going on is one thing which is
certainly front of mine for everyone but
I do think that for us for my kids for
you for you know for people to make no
apologies for being frustrated or
wanting sports or their life back that's
the human feeling and I think that
sometimes we feel like we got to
suppress that for fear of shame or being
critiqued or judge where I don't think
that that's completely fair because I
don't think that they all it's kind of
mutually exclusive you know you can
still feel what people are going through
but I still think that I don't think we
should feel bad about talking sports and
wanting sports is that fair no I think
it's absolutely fair you know
we hear from people who are saying I
needed a break you know someone shows in
the hospital I'm wondering about what's
going on with my job and I want to you
know I wanted some sports or I want to
talk about it or you know I want to
chime in right now I mean we hear that
all the time right now and then and then
I look up and I see a highlight of from
the South Korean baseball league and I'm
seeing somebody circle the bases and I'm
seeing the crack of the bat and I'm like
man oh man oh man do I miss Major League
Baseball that's what I think about Dave
yeah and I'm with you and I think that
obviously were biased because we're tied
to the industry but I see that I see
that happening outside of our country
which which you know to each his own and
I understand that but I do think that
with baseball and you have a grasp on
football basketball all sports but I
think that with baseball in particular
it's our season right now I think it's
an opportunity I guess to kind of put a
phrase to gain gain some market share
back you know from football and
basketball I think that being in homes
of of Americans all over the country and
it just kind of takes him back to my
father who passed away four years ago
where he said man we're in Houston with
my siblings we used to hug around for
that game of the week whether it be on
TV or the radio and just listen to it or
watch it where baseball has that
opportunity and yeah it's gonna look
different without the fans but I do
think that and I was dead on if you
heard this rich is potentially having
players coaches miked up so it gives the
fans that the viewers a different
perspective so this is all contingent
that we do get something death okay so
let's let's get into it a little bit
Dave Roberts LA Dodgers manager here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you know
about the proposal that that major
league baseball ownership and management
approved Monday to give to the players
and where that stands right now so I
think that I know that they proposed it
like you got like everyone knows and I
guess it's in the players court to kind
of counter and to kind of figure out
some consensus so I think that initially
as I understand it that there was going
to be a proration of salaries but then
that was the fine print of the bylaw
whatever was
an amendment potentially if we were
going to reason without fans and that's
the case right now so I think there's a
50/50 share of revenues but I really
don't know specifically rich what it
intent so regular season postseason what
that really means I it's kind of above
my paygrade sure I'm just more motivated
that both sides want to play and I think
that there's a bigger picture you know
for the game itself for the owners for
the players for the fans so I just don't
think you hear to stop it anymore of a
stoppage I would make sense so what do
you know though about the actual
logistics because I imagine that's
something you as a manager will really
have to master and figure out and at
some point it's potentially where you
you will be not only figuring out a
lineup card but who's who's tested that
day in the results yet before you can
fill out a card right I mean like that
right that's right and I do think risk
that there's gonna be there has to be
sufficient and enough quantity to kind
of justify it so whether it's an every
other day a couple times a week
obviously you're going to be tested with
temperature each day trainers players
coaches there's gonna be some situation
where I think they're doing it in Asia
where you know there's an app where you
have to kind of document your symptoms
where you're at your temperature before
you even get through the door and then
do some kind of hands-on stuff with with
training staff I think the rosters will
be expanded which they should be because
of an abbreviated spring training which
we're used to as far as you know the six
week versus two to three week situation
don't really know where that's going to
be at I do think that the the
realignment of divisions the three kind
of deal I think that makes sense as far
as geography and kind of keeping players
staff you know when you start travel
you're talking about airline attendants
and things like that keeping them the
less is is better so that's some of the
things I think there's an expanded
playoff roster or team situation which I
think also makes sense with it being
sort of a sprint rather than a marathon
like normally as for us
and
what about social distancing Dave no
dugouts no clubhouses I mean is that
something that you're you're you're
discussing right now what's the what's
the status on something like that well I
do know that if you're talking about
spring training in Arizona you have
access to or Arizona and Florida you
have access to bigger club houses
because you're used to bigger numbers
but then the numbers that were used to
in regular spring training will be
curtailed but if you're talking about
each individual city and stadium the
spring training then you're talking
about the other's visiting dugout or
Clubhouse as well so that will kind of
now you're getting essentially half your
team on the other side of the UH in the
visiting side with the trainers and half
on the home side so that'll kind of
allow for the social distance think
that's kind of initial ground-floor kind
of thinking and then in terms of a
dugout will you use the stands if
there's no players and then I guess in
terms of a game you you can't use the
clubhouse I guess right except maybe to
have to take care of some quick business
or honestly like this is this is exactly
the sort of stuff you need to figure out
before you and as a manager you need to
know this stuff you do you do and that's
why it's like I've worked and I feel
that you know each of us managers have
work really closely with our training
staffs in front office but no more than
this time because I think that it's it's
certainly way bigger than just you know
baseball so now you know these guys are
getting the trainers I say these guys
that the training staff is getting
information from health officials which
is getting kind of filtered down to the
front office to the coaches to myself
and so this is something that we need to
know in real time every single day and
yeah if something does happen you that
also have an alternate plan for that and
what's the protocol for that
so it's interesting cuz what we can't do
is you can't start baseball to then have
to shut it down so we have to get our
ducks all in line and how close Dave
Roberts are the Dodgers how close do you
think baseball is to getting these ducks
in line as the the hashing out between
the Players Association and management
goes down well yeah
you know I think that that's that
ongoing negotiation is one driver but I
also think that you know you're talking
about state to state you're talking
about the government officials as far as
giving us the green light and what we
can and can't do but I think that for
our part as far as the industry we got
to kind of come to some consensus and
then now once we get the green light
hopefully as we look out two three four
weeks from now things will start to get
more clear and that will kind of open up
some options but I think right now rich
we're more in the mode of okay players
union and major league baseball figure
it out let's get it done and as far as
each individual organization because I
talk to managers around baseball we're
now internally we're trying to figure
out how it looks like how it looks like
for us and have different plans whether
it's a twenty seven thirty thirty five
fifty man spring training is it here is
that there's your kind of got planned
ABCDE yeah my head spinning Dave I mean
I like that and then so um how about
what about this issue Dave and again I
know you're you're you're involved in
managing a baseball team but these are
such bigger issues to that's in the
world the the Governor of Arizona says
yes sports leagues can return in the
middle of May and you're in a County in
Los Angeles that's saying no we're
sheltering in place for another three
months potentially so what what is that
a competition problem again I know that
we're talking about life issues but we
are talking about you're gonna be
managing a baseball team would you have
an issue if the Diamondbacks had
different rules about what they can do
and prepare for a game than you you know
what it's interesting that's a great
question and I and I think that you know
the overarching I think it's totally
fair for the governor to do that and I
think that when you're talking about
state to state city to city there's a
density situation where Arizona is not
as dense as Los Angeles so that kind of
unleashing taking the reigns down I
think that completely makes sense now
you're talking about the competition
thing well you're already looking at a
short
I do think that there's a certain clear
advantage to it to an organization being
able to kind of come together and go to
work business as usual and have an extra
week to two weeks tennis whatever the
number of you know ramped up that we
wouldn't have so that's a different
discussion so I think that you know the
net for me I would rather teams open up
together and I guess then again a
question we were you know I asked
Charlie Blackmon the other day of the
Rockies who I'm imagining you would be
in some form of a close proximity enough
to to maybe play he's like you know what
I'll quarantine if that's what it means
I'll quarantine if that's what it takes
are you hearing that the teams will have
to quarantine are you talking to your
players about that right now if we are
six weeks away maybe from no no and I I
applaud Charlie's feeling that way but I
think that every player and family is
different and I think that which is fair
which is real and I think that they're
real the reality or the idea of corn
chaining solo I think it's unrealistic
the overall you know majority I think
that what I do count on is that the
players and their families realize how
serious decision is so once we do kind
of move forward I would like to think
everyone takes it serious and it is
responsible because yeah one family
member one player being irresponsible
could affect you know not only their
club but the industry itself so there
there's always going to be some margin
of risk as we all understand that going
forward but I do think that that
quarantine individually for players is
certainly unrealistic no I I hear you I
mean you're ten years removed from being
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma I'm
sure you also have members of the staff
that are there are all older and
potentially in in the the I guess age
range of being more vulnerable I mean
this is serious business man and it's
that's the thing is that we can talk
baseball I can you talk baseball and
sports with you sure for the next two
hours but I do think that it is
important for us to kind of as you kind
of brought brought it to light is like
you've got to be prepared forever
serious business and I'm a cancer
survivor so am i more in jeopardy than
somebody else that's 25 that's
completely healthy has no history and
it's always one of those things where
it's all good until it's not right so
it's like I feel good but if someone is
infected and then something really goes
down the wrong path then now what you
know so we have to really take it
serious which I know we are as an
industry in sports across you know our
country and I think the conversations
like this are this are healthy but I
also think as we kind of started this
segment and just talking sports it's
healthy as well yep absolutely before I
let you go Dave and I really appreciate
the time and next time we have you on
maybe we can go deep into deep into
sports I'll ask you the ultimate
question I'm sure you're being asked by
friends family if you're on any of these
uh these zoom I guess dinner parties or
anything like that
you must be asked this so well I'll just
go ahead and ask it do you think this is
gonna happen do you think we will have
baseball Dave I do I do
III I think we will play baseball this
year yes I'll go for it man if we can
all be healthy and do it my kids cannot
get it open Dave I have a my wife has a
photographs on her desk at home and I
get emotional talk about this of my two
boys I have a daughter who's six she
wants to go back to Dodger Stadium like
she loves going there but I've got my
two boys I took a quick snap of one of
them and a quick snap of another of them
you know one to the other if you
remember back to back-to-back home runs
that you guys hit over for the
Diamondbacks and in Greinke right I mean
it was and I took a snap of of the of my
kids seeing a ball leave the yard for
back to back to back home run they've
never seen anything like that before or
since
and we need it man we need it but
obviously everybody's got to be safe to
do it you know it's that simple that is
so cool and that's something that your
kids are gonna remember forever and
that's what the thing is that these
athletes are just so talented and these
moments yes rich it's gonna be different
I'm still hopeful like I said but you're
gonna be in your living room watching
the Dodgers you know play and that look
that'll be a lot of fun too and talk
talk about the players and that'll be a
different dynamic but it'll be fun
in the meantime my wife the Red Sox fan
will just show him on YouTube you
stealing a base against the Yankees in
2004 Dave and then I'll have to as a
Yankee fan turn it off
you know that in the meantime that's
what we'll have to do you know you take
care of yourself Dave I always love our
chats thanks for coming on
right back at you that's Dave Roberts is
very few like him hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here